la violencia volvió a ser la
protagonista de un día sagrado en
jerusalén
tuvimos que salir de la mezquita de
al-aqsa después del resto de la mañana y
luego los colonos judíos empezaron a
entrar nos están invadiendo en grandes
grupos ya se sabe que durante esta
festividad los judíos nos invaden cada
canción
este palestino se refiere a la llegada
de fieles judíos a la explanada de las
mezquitas un lugar supuestamente
exclusivo para la oración musulmana
durante y después del rezo matutino del
ramadán que había congregado a miles de
musulmanes llegaron devotos judíos
escoltados por la policía israelí
aunque sólo pueden acudir como
visitantes varios llegaron orando una
grave ofensa para los palestinos
los enfrentamientos dejaron decenas de
palestinos heridos y detenidos el pasado
viernes los choques fueron todavía más
violentos y se saldaron con más de 150
personas heridas
por primera vez en décadas la semana
santa el ramadán y el pesar judío se
superponen y salen a relucir las
tensiones históricas en la ciudad de
jerusalén sagrada para las tres
religiones
recientemente las fuerzas de israelíes
mataron a una decena de palestinos en
violentas redadas como respuesta a dos
ataques palestinos en israel que se
saldaron con 14 muertes el temor es que
las tensiones exploten como el año
pasado cuando los enfrentamientos en la
explanada de las mezquitas terminaron en
una dura guerra en gaza que se cobró la
vida de 250 palestinos y 13 israelíes